Shakespeare didn't sound like this and
he didn't sound like this either but if
you were back in 1610 and you snagged a
couple front-row tickets to the globe
what kind of English would you hear
[Music]
I have a confession a tough one for a
language nerd here goes I never really
got into Shakespeare
I remember the theater geeks the girl
with one hand raised head turned
chanting lines to whom exactly maybe a
poetry loving squirrel that wasn't for
me I was into Legos and languages which
is how I ended up unintentionally
parsing Homer in Greek before I had to
face Shakespeare yes
had to a class assignment I think it was
the tempest I skimmed just enough to
pass a quiz then I honestly would have
shelved the bard forever but for that
one stray remark as the theater geeks
donned their best British accent a
random gadfly sneered hey you know what
Shakespeare really sounded like he
sounded like us know what had I miss
something about Shakespeare something
that took linguistic detective work to
solve something like his pores spelling
it's there in the bad cortos secretly
scribbled by some bootleggers in the
audience it's there in the good quarters
in the First Folio - even on his own
grave dig and friend look almost
childish and stacked they and that keep
a simplified Germanic letters Thorne hmm
this isn't his spelling 1,400 Chaucer's
English was a very readable Tonga so
readable that 75 years later mr. Caxton
imported a printing press to cash in on
that readability but one day a merchant
came to town and ordered eggs a woman
said sorry a speck no fringe the
merchant got mad he wasn't speaking
French he just wanted some eggs someone
jumped in to help oh he means errand
taxes in private though what shall the
man in these days new race eggs or
errand unleash the spelling debates how
to spell Knecht when it was evolving
into mate should correction have a sea
and why oh why did Chaucer's valve fall
apart so fast
by 1600 the ongoing great vowel shift
was turning me into ie a became e and o
was ooh welcome to early modern English
Shakespeare's tongue good friend for
Jesus sake forbear to dig the dust and
close a tear not here
err just one of many rhymes that well
they aren't rhymes anymore
Pledis rhymed with dread are with her
and own with alone you find creators
resin I was fine with company shoulder
kept it all and didn't match would extra
credit spell two words that sound like
society and rhyme with variety haha
you get gland pray and pray and sad but
then the rhymes were saying so it where
all of these actually eat or maybe he
was there
well fortunately we find ear witness
accounts of a meet meet murder say was
in the process of merging with C with
caution
rhymes may even help us recover puns
like probably resins and maybe bio and
rhythm like those ions my teacher made
us drum out in class those count how
many syllables were in say in close up
to two syllables except here it demands
three and close it meter can also reveal
stress not housewifery but is afraid
okay you're learning now you see in sand
says a noun and a verb it's no longer
strange for you to hear or you know the
resin light and you can stomach the news
that Shakespeare's name may have been
Shakespeare or sh x bear in 1889
Alexander Ellis added one more piece of
evidence modern dialects dialects
contain traces of a time before English
had a proper accent people who still
don't merge meet with mint witches that
aren't witches under opt ours H list
arts and jaren end ins
sounds downright Shakespearean like some
dialects still do he use both though and
polite you the left is our CH you have
your and that third person if like in
shaft was still competing with us and
well data crunchers deflate legends of
his peerless vocabulary
he was endlessly invented with meaning
and syntax try out this word order the
lie with days and with rewarded
threatened a new courage I'm not doing
it on being done playful at angle for
audiences to untie on the spot so what
about listening to a whole play linguist
David crystal tested that in a newly
reconstructed globe thrown back into an
era of standing heckling and opie
original pronunciation play goers
detected suspicious traces of one
particular dialect their own there's
something Universal about learning to
pronounce we all come as strangers to
Shakespeare sound whether you're a
theater geek who quotes Hamlet by heart
or your me who I'm about to finish
animating this and read it for the very
first time I think you patrons from
locking this and keeping me creating and
to everyone watching by private RA
unsubscribe for language
[Music]
you